I'VE BEEN HERE LONGER.
I HOPE YOU HAVE A GREAT TIME
WITH YOUR FAMILY.
YOU DESERVE IT.
WELCOME TO HANNITY.
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
WE HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU THAT WE
HAVE BEEN EXPECTING THE RESULTS
OF FOUR INVESTIGATIONS INTO THE
DEEP STATE.
BREAKING TONIGHT, ACCORDING TO
OUR SOURCES, THE FIRST OF THOSE
REPORTS IS SET TO BE RELEASED
SOON.
MAYBE AS EARLY AS TOMORROW.
DOJ INSPECTOR GENERAL'S OFFICIAL
FINANCE
FINDINGS ARE NOW IN.
WE ARE TOLD THAT THE FORMER
REPORT WILL STRONGLY REBUKE HIS
UTTER LACK OF CANDOR.
THAT MEANS LINE.
WE ARE ALSO BEING TOLD THAT THE
REPORT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL IS
PUTTING OUT TOMORROW HAS
REPORTED COMEY FOR LEAKING MEMOS
AND DETAILED CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE PRESIDENT, A CLEAR VIOLATION
OF THE ESPIONAGE ACT.
THESE DOCUMENTS WERE SO
SENSITIVE, ONE MONTH AFTER HE
WAS FIRED, THE FBI AGENT SHOWED
UP AT HIS FRONT DOOR TO RETRIEVE
THE MEMOS AND INTERROGATE COMEY
ABOUT HIS RAPID MISCONDUCT.
AS OF NOW, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAS REPORTEDLY DECIDED NOT TO AT
THIS MOMENT CHARGE COMEY OVER
THIS CRIMINAL REFERRAL.
HOWEVER, THIS IS WHAT IS A TINY
PIECE OF WHAT THE BIGGER REPORT
WILL BE AND THE THREE MAJOR
REPORTS THAT ARE COMING, AND
WITHOUT A DOUBT, COMEY SHOULD BE
SWEATING A LOT TONIGHT ABOUT
WHAT SHOULD BE IN THOSE REPORTS.
THIS REPORT IS EXPECTED TO BE
THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG WHEN IT
COMES TO JIM COMEY.
WE WILL GET THE FISA, FULL FISA
ABUSE REPORT BY THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
AS WE HAVE LONG REPORTED, JIM
COMEY IS PLAYING A STARRING ROLE
IN THAT INVESTIGATION.
REMEMBER, HE HAS SIGNED THREE OF
THOSE FISA APPLICATIONS.
ALL OF THEM, HE HAD BEEN WARNED
ABOUT.
ALL OF THEM, THE BULK OF THE
INFORMATION, HILLARY CLINTON'S
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN
DOSSIER.
BLAKELY, RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
FROM THE GET-GO.
THIS WAS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
SPYING ON A PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE AND THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
THEY WERE ALSO USED IN AN
ATTEMPT TO DESTROY A DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
ON WHAT ARE THE ORIGINS OF THE
RUSSIA PROBE.
THIS REPORT WILL DIG INTO HOW
AMERICA'S POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE WERE USED AND
ABUSED AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP
CAMPAIGN PAID AND THEN,
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AND ALSO, WHETHER IN FACT
ILLEGAL SPINE INCURRED.
THEY WERE DESIGNED TO CIRCUMVEN
CIRCUMVENT.
THAT WILL BE A BOMBSHELL.
JAMES COMEY IS ALSO.
ALSO, ANDY McCARTHY, AS HE
POINTS OUT IN A BRAND-NEW BOOK,
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION UNLESS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WAS INVOLVED.
THAT WOULD MEAN, AT SOME POINT,
AS THESE REPORTS NOW COME OUT
ONE AFTER ANOTHER,
PRESIDENT OBAMA MUST BE ASKED
UNDER OATH, WHAT DID YOU KNOW
ABOUT YOUR COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION AND WHEN DID YOU